sixième journée de manifestations dans
tout le chili est ici dans la capitale
le rassemblement se fait toujours autour
de la plaza italia
les chiliens protestent contre la vie
chère et les services sociaux santé
éducation retraite insuffisant tous à la
suite d'une augmentation du ticket de
métro
les chiliens eux mêmes noms reviennent
pas leur audace c'est du jamais vu
maintenant je lis à des manifestations
qui n'avait pas vécu je pense pas depuis
trente ans même en dictature c'est
quelque chose de complètement nouveau
c'est inédit exceptionnel et pourtant le
président sebastian pinera espérait bien
calmer les choses
tard hier soir il a annoncé plusieurs
réformes des retraites du revenu minimum
de la santé des impôts pour les plus
pauvres
surtout il a reconnu une situation
intenable est assez patiente des nectars
d avance
une situation d'inégalité d'abus qui a
conduit à l'expression franche et
authentique 2 millions et millions de
chiliens dit il plus encore ils en
demandent pardon de conques aux états
baltes harrison et l'épisode personne à
me contacter pardon pour lui son
gouvernement et les gouvernements qui
l'ont précédé incapable de reconnaître
l'ampleur du malaise
eh bien ça ne passe pas les gens en ont
assez et on parle même de révolution
pas question se contenter de miettes
les gens en ont assez la tmp ya cinq ans
elle parade pour ses cinq fils il faut
payer pour tous ses des concessions je
pense cosmétiques
c'est vrai mais pas vraiment un
changement du modèle économique conac
n'a eu depuis trente ans et que même le
gouvernement devait gauche on était plus
ou moins d'à part je pense comme tous
les soirs les manifestations vont
dégénérer en affrontement avec blain des
gaz lacrymogènes et lances à eau
il y aura encore des victimes est de
plus en plus de plaintes contre la
répression des carabiniers et de l'armée
vingt mille soldats patrouillent dans
les rues du jamais vu depuis la
dictature